playing used to water bomb bush fires in
Australia is feared to have crashed
authorities lost contact with the c-130
aircraft in the snowy manaro region
Andrew Thomas is live for us in Sydney
with the latest so Andrew what are you
learning about what what what's going on
well Rochelle just in the last hour of
the emergency services agency here has
confirmed that they've lost contact with
a plane they believed it to have crashed
now there aren't that many planes
believe it or not that have been
fighting these bush fires there are a
couple of 737 jets a dc-10 but the one
that is believed to have crashed is a
Hercules c-130 now that's the biggest
plane that the Rural Fire Service here
has been using to fight these
unprecedented fires it's a very big
plane and it's believed to have crashed
about two or three hours ago now just
south of the capital of Australia
Canberra now if it is that plane there
are normally three people on board and
given where it's crashed if it has then
it's very unlikely that those people
have survived now we've filmed this
plane a couple of weeks ago fighting the
fires it's being used consistently
throughout the last month or so as these
unprecedented bush fires are taking hold
right across the southeast of Australia
this plane and others they dump fire
retardant as well pink powder on the
ground to stop fires spreading but this
obviously would be a major disaster in
these bush fires if we haven't seen
enough of those with a number of lives
lost with homes destroyed over the last
month or so now we know that helicopters
are looking for any wreckage there are
ambulances driving to this fairly remote
area as well so far no confirmation of
any wreckage and at the moment no
confirmation either of the exact plane
involved but to say we believe it's a
c-130 normally a transport plane
converted into a firefighting plane we
believe it's that one that's gone down
okay Andrew Thomas with the latest
forest from Sydney thank you Andrew